well well by the time I was 9 or 10 I
was earnest practitioner of ceremonial
magic and I would draw Pentacles in my
room and burden rosemary and I was also
an altar boy at this time and it made
some problem I recall one time I don't
know how many of you are are recovering
Catholics but there's a thing which they
bring out once a year I don't know if
they still do this they sort of left the
faith but they have this thing which
they use at midnight mass and Easter
called them asked for gilliam and it
looks like a baby's rattle and you put
it in water and it has holes in the
round head and it fills with holy water
and then you can fling holy water great
distances with this thing and so one day
back in the sacristy we were cleaning
out some things and they came up the
priest came upon this old ask for
gilliam and I said whoa he was about to
get rid of it and I said well I have a
use for that and he said Oh what what is
your youth for this my son and I said
well I'm involved in the conjuration of
as IL xi general of the mercuric sphere
and it's a it's launched an
investigation that has made that town
unsafe for the practice of ceremonial
magic to this day
but the point of my story is they
needn't have worried because and I I
don't want to step on anybody's toes
that look unpaid to be controversial you
understand
so they needn't have worried because at
least for this
lumpam Irishman it didn't work no matter
how much rosemary I burned no matter how
many wax vigils were formed no matter
how many even more peculiar things were
undertaken it didn't seem to cut the
mustard and them around the time that I
was 14 or so I had many obsessions and
my life seems ruled by obsession and at
some point I became aware that there was
a book at the library that they didn't
want me to read this was when I was
somewhat younger and they didn't want me
to read this book and the librarian who
was friends with my mother had been told
if he asked for this book don't let him
have it so I not only determined to read
the book I determined to read every book
the author had ever written and the book
was brave new world which I don't know
how many of you have read it it wouldn't
sir a small wind these days but it did
involve all the women did wear these
prophylactics some kind of I never quite
understood what it was but if some kind
of first control kit that they wore on
the belt and of course people were grown
in vast and had very free sex and so
forth and so on it was an interesting
book but then I started reading the
author Aldous Huxley and I read chrome
yellow and I read antic hay and I read
after many of summer dies the Swan and I
read dates and napkins and some of these
things were like screenplays and some
were comedies of British manners I kept
hoping we'd get back to the prophylactic
belt
and instead eventually I came upon the
doors of perception and read this book
and it was like it had never entered my
mind the concept of drug intoxication
information from reflection of that sort
I mean the whole thing was just
completely puzzling to me and I can
remember following my mother around the
kitchen of our suburban home saying if
1/10 of what this guy is saying is true
this is the most amazing thing in the
world well now we know that that's a
very mild book very limited in its
claims I mean he talks about staring at
the folds of his trousers and thinking
about Hildegard von Bingen and it's
basically presented as a thought thing
and most of you look like you're
probably not old enough to remember but
there was a point in the evolution of
awareness about the psychedelic
experience where the way people did it
is they piled up art book favorite
recordings foods perfumes and then they
would get loaded and then they would
look at the art book see the orange
smell the perfume it's not a bad yeah
it's not a bad idea
but that that was the clue to me that
there was something going on and I other
say I was about 14 and I had a lot ahead
of me before I really took my first trip
and I was trying to figure it out
shopping in the in the supermarket of
ideas of the time reading Camus reading
michi reading Sartre and all these
people are a huge downer as any of you
know who've read them I mean the entire
tone of modernity is just one big downer
after another you know if it's not Hana
rent on the triviality of e holo then
it's Karl Jasper's on something else or
Sartre and it just horrible horrible
stuff well so I I became aware through
Huxley that there was this other
possibility and and I in Huxley always
wrote about the psychedelic experience
as a branch of the mystical quest what
he told the perennial philosophy and so
I started reading both the scholars of
mysticism such as Evelyn Underhill and
[Music]
William James varieties of the religious
experience and so forth on and I started
reading the primary sources Teresa of
ávila Thomas trehearne Jakub Burma
what's the singing Hildegard one thing
in all of these people and and I got the
ideas that there was this experience but
I couldn't find it I couldn't find it in
you know on my knees at the church for
hour after hour I mean I found various
forms of existential boredom at
infinitum but actual and I would sit in
nature and I would hyperventilate and I
would do all these things
well the juice just wasn't coming well
to make a long story short
eventually like lots and lots of people
and by my own personal route I found my
way to these things and they are to my
mind astonishing worthy of taking risk
or because they work